[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
ici depuis bruxelles depuis le parlement
européen pour cette nouvelle saison
d'europe hebdo nous ouvrirons chaque
semaine ensemble les portes de l'europe
au programme de ce premier numéro
peut-on interdire le bifff aux tats en
tout cas en autriche c'est possible et
ce depuis juillet dernier c'est devenu
le premier pays l'union européenne à
interdire complètement l'herbicide sur
son territoire un état peut-il interdire
le glyphosate alors que l'union
européenne l'autorisent
comment les consommateurs les citoyens
européens peuvent-ils se protégeait des
pesticides et bien nous ouvrirons le
débat avec nos invités en plateau mais
avant retour sur le sujet qui agite
l'europe depuis plus de trois ans le
break site
et ce alors que la cour suprême
britannique vient de juger illégale la
décision de suspendre le parlement
décidé par boris johnson
un nouveau revers pour le premier
ministre britannique donc pour ceux qui
n'auraient pas tout suivi
aurélie d'afas a résumé pour vous les
derniers rebondissements de ce
feuilleton britannique aux européens
[Musique]
plus de trois ans après le vote des
britanniques après déjà deux reports de
la date du bric site
c'est désormais un second premier
ministre de mener le pays hors de
l'union européenne en juillet dernier
boris johnson succède à theresa may à la
tête du gouvernement britannique
et il hérite d'une situation bloquée si
theresa may avait réussi à négocier un
accord de sortie avec les 27
elle a échoué par trois fois à le faire
adopter devant son parlement
d'entrée de jeu boris johnson près par
les britanniques au no deal une sortie
sans accord au 31 octobre
il est bien sûr vital que nous nous
préparions à l'éventualité lointaine que
bruxelles refuse de poursuivre les
négociations et que nous soyons
contraints de ne conclure aucun accord
un mois plus tard afin d'avoir les
coudées franches
il tente de suspendre l'activité
parlementaire jusqu'au 14 octobre soit
15 jours avant la date du breakbeat
indignation à la chambre et dans la rue
recours à la cour suprême et échec de la
manoeuvre du premier ministre
la cour bien de juger illégale cette
décision des scores assez court a déjà
conclu que le conseil du premier
ministre à sa majesté était illégale
nulle et sans effet cela signifie que le
décret auquel il a donné lieu et est
également illégale nulle et sans effet
et doit être annulée
le parlement va siéger à nouveau boris
johnson devra composer avec le débat
parlementaire
alors qu'il tente en parallèle de
négocier un nouvel accord avec l'union
européenne
en cas d'impasse au 19 octobre ces
députés lui ont déjà imposé une loi anti
no deal ils seraient obligés de demander
aux européens un troisième report du
bric site
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau christian allard bonjour vous
êtes député européen depuis mai dernier
vous appartenait au parti
indépendantiste écossais et vous siégez
ici à bruxelles
dans le groupe les verts bon bienvenus
vous vous présentez souvent comme 100%
écossais 100% français je précise que
vous êtes né en bourgogne 100% européen
pour planter le décor autant dire que
vous étiez et vous êtes opposés aux
briques site
bien sûr bonjour et bienvenue je suis
opposé du président pour ces raisons là
parce que le 21e siècle aujourd'hui
quand les barrières tombent petit à
petit entre les pays entre nos cultures
entre nos citoyens le brésil se
retourner aux années de 1950
ou peut-être même avant donc cela ce
n'est pas du tout une idée du 21e siècle
je n'ai pas une idée du tout pour
l'europe et certainement pas pour les
cosses alors on l'a vu il ya des
rebondissements quotidiens toutes les
semaines voir tous les jours et hier
c'est la cour suprême britannique qui a
validé la décision de boris johnson de
suspendre le parlement jusque à la
mi-octobre cela change quoi est ce que
cela veut dire que on va être obligés de
renégocier un accord avant le 31 octobre
d'une certaine chose ça change beaucoup
et d'un autre côté ça ne change rien
à pourquoi parce que boris johnson
exactement de la même position que
theresa may c'est de dire qu'il n'a pas
l'accord du parlement britannique pour
pouvoir sortir de l'union européenne
c'est d'accord il ne l'a pas je ne pense
pas qu'il l'aura il a certainement pas
un accord pour sortir de l'union
européenne le 31 octobre c'est pour la
raison pour laquelle il a voulu un petit
peut être contre la démocratie et
empêché la chambre d'écho main à
des communes a siégé pour pendant
quelques semaines et ça ça a été prouvé
par la cour suprême que c'était illégal
et et j'en suis très content j'en suis
très content et ma tonne maintenant je
ne sais pas si boris johnson sera le
prochain premier ministre le projet le
premier ministre à la fin de cette
semaine
ce qu'il faut se remettre à mon avis oui
je ne dis pas au niveau du bras exit
haut niveau rope et grande bretagne
mais en grande bretagne où absolument en
croire le times ne savons pas qui sera
le premier ministre demain
est ce que le parlement va augmenter
valent à la pression sur d'origine
semaines pour négocier justement avec
l'union européenne au absolument puisque
boris johnson n'a pas négocié du tout
avec l'union européenne depuis que
l'état s'en défend et je redis il a
envoyé un papy qui s'appelle le nom
papier j'aurais bien savoir ce que ce
qui est un non papillon papier c'est
signé rien dessus ce qui a été prouvé
cette semaine c'est que et on le savait
personne ne peut avoir confiance en
boris johnson
boris johnson c'est quelqu'un qui nous
ne peux pas croire un mot de ce qu'il va
dire il ne sait pas du tout ce qui va le
faire demain
la seule chose qu'on sait c'est que
boris johnson veut rester premier
ministre
à mon avis après la décision cette
semaine elle doit absolument
démissionner et on doit changer
le premier ministre en grande-bretagne
alors vous avez à la démission en début
de semaine michel barnier le négociateur
de l'union européenne sur le bric site
pour l'union européenne semblait
pessimiste quant à l'issue des
négociations
je vous propose de l'écouter en crainte
uk thinking sur la base de la position
britannique actuel il est difficile de
voir comment nous pouvons parvenir à une
solution juridiquement opérationnelle
qui répondent à tous les objectifs du
filet de sécurité mais non cela dit nous
restons ouverts aux pourparlers au
progrès et à l'écouté des nouvelles
idées du royaume uni
y compris en ce qui concerne les
relations futures jeunes chip christian
allard vous aussi vous partagez ce
pessimisme absolument je ne vois pas du
tout comment l'union européenne peut
répondre entre milices comme je lui dis
on ne sait pas s'il sera toujours là en
fin de semaine ou un parlement qui n'est
pas d'accord donc nous devons avoir la
place et le temps pour pouvoir changer
notre premier ministre
changer le parlement est peut-être avoir
un autre référendum c'est pour ça que je
demande au moins un an s'il n'est pas
deux ans pour être sûr un recharge pour
tout changer il faut absolument ne pas
revenir où nous étions nous sommes
depuis trois ans et demi ou vraiment ça
n'apporte aucune solution nous doit tron
trouver une solution et là il nous faut
le temps alors justement vous parlez de
changer de premier ministre est ce que
boris johnson il est discrédité aux yeux
des institutions à des dominions
européenne
vous pouvez pas être plus discrédité que
ça que que votre cour suprême qui
visitent vous a dit que vous avez menti
à la reine et que vous avez fait quelque
chose qui est complètement illégal
d'avoir fermé les portes d'un parlement
et surtout en grande-bretagne où le
régime c'est un régime démocratique
c'est un jeu régime de parlements de par
le mans c'est le parlement qui a le plus
de pouvoir
alors vous parliez de la nécessité
d'avoir un an supplémentaire pour sortir
de ce marasme
à quoi servirait un troisième report un
délai supplémentaire on sait que dans
les négociations il ya la question
notamment du bac stop de la frontière
entre les deux irlande
j'étais une réunion ce matin au sujet du
bac stop on peut trouver toutes les
solutions qu'on veut si le premier
ministre et si le parlement britannique
n'est pas d'accord c'est pas la peine
que l'union européenne réfléchit souhait
c'est de travailler sur un programme ou
sur une solution que le premier ministre
le parlement n'est pas d'accord dont
nous devons
celui ci n'est ce problème en
grande-bretagne à londres à westminster
le 17 et le 18 octobre prochain se
tiendra un sommet européen capital
puisqu'il ya ici décidera aussi l'avenir
du royaume uni jusqu'à présent les 27
états membres ont plutôt affiché leur
unité sur la question du break site
est-ce que vous pensez que cela va
continuer j'espère j'espère qu'ils
gardent leur dignité c'est très très
important et je demande au nom de
l'école selon la grande bretagne de nous
donner une chance de prouver que nous
pouvons peut-être resté que toute la
grande bretagne reste dans l'union
européenne et si ce n'est pas possible
au moins que les causes restent dans
l'union européenne
merci christian l'art d'avoir répondu à
nos questions nous doute que nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler
sur ce plateau alors qu'en france on
t'aime continue à tergiverser sur les
zones d'épandage
prenons maintenant la direction de
l'autriche premier pays de l'union
européenne avoir complètement interdit
de l'ifo that en juillet dernier si la
décision du parlement a les faveurs de
l'opinion publique autrichienne elle
reste menacé vous allez loire et en
attendant certains agriculteurs
continuent d'utiliser l'herbicide
controversé ne compte pas s'en passer
c'est un reportage de faveur et qu' air
[Musique]
une exploitation céréalière en
basse-autriche du blé de la betterave du
maïs et des pommes de terre sur ses 110
hectares de cultures lorenz meyer emploi
du glyphosate
pas question pour lui de s'en passer
j'utilise de litres de round up pour 10
ha du et dans 100 litres d'eau en emploi
pour environ 15 à 20 % de ma surface
cultivée cet été lawrence a récolté du
blé sur cette parcelle au printemps li
plantera du maïs mais entre deux
cultures pour protéger le sol de la
pluie et lutter contre l'érosion
il a fait pousser du sarrasin une
technique répandue en autriche où
l'agriculture se pratique souvent en
pente
regardez ces petites racines elles
stabilisent la terre et favorise la
présence de vers de terre qui
fertilisent le sol mais au milieu de ces
plantes poussent aussi des mauvaises
herbes
lawrence ne veut pas désherber avec une
machine désherber mécaniquement implique
de retourner la terre sur deux ou trois
centimètres et donc d'annuler les
bénéfices qu'offrent cette technique
c'est pourquoi j'utilise du glyphosate
le feuillage reste au sol et les racines
restent intactes des arguments que les
ong connaissent bien le biologiste
hellmuth booster milite pour l'abandon
des pesticides et sans discernement
ces arguments sont utilisés depuis
longtemps par l'industrie pour défendre
le glyphosate and funding austria massif
comme on commence à savoir en faire un
outil de protection de la biodiversité
ou même quand il est différent
des arguments repris par les syndicats
qui sont très écoutés par les
agriculteurs sur ce qu'il convient de
faire pour produire stand place
fontinettes fait des producteurs nantais
c'est une formation en est or toutes les
alternatives écologiques sont absentes
de ces argumentaires kolodjay
alternatives de production se coupent
les micros
pourtant les alternatives existent
l'autriche fait même figure de modèle un
quart de sa surface agricole des
cultivées en bio
sur les bords du lac de nos idoles c'est
le temps des vendanges
geeraert ribao moeurs viticulteurs n'est
pas conventionné en bio pour autant il
ne veut pas entendre parler de
glyphosate dans ses vignes vous voyez il
y à une abeille qui vient butiner du
pollen sur ce plan de rouquette en
fleurs qu'en mars on peut en manger
mesdames et ni la bei ni moi ne
pourrions déguster ses feuilles
si on employait de l'herbicide on
cela fait des milliers d'années que l'on
cultive la vigne dans la région on nous
propose des pesticides depuis à peine 50
ans on a réussi à s'en passer avant
différentes sa femme et les caennais
obtient et pour notre famille
ça n'est pas une option en contrepartie
il y a un peu plus d'efforts à fournir
pour désherber mécaniquement mais nous
travaillons surtout avec des moutons
la démarche de gerhardt ribao moeurs a
le vent en poupe en autriche
malgré tout la décision du parlement
autrichien d'interdire le glyphosate en
2020 reste fragile
elle a été voté contre l'avis du
gouvernement conservateur
ce fut un long chemin mais pour la
première fois depuis des décennies nous
avons pu trouver une majorité au
parlement sans les voix du parti
conservateur csu et chaque espèce
nous avons notifié la commission
européenne de cette décision qui peut
maintenant rendre son avis gameiro mais
je suis persuadé que l'europe ne dira
pas un état membre de continuer à
répandre du poison sur ses chances n'en
déplaise à ce député
rien n'est moins sûr les défenseurs de
l'herbicide pourrait s'appuyer sur un
avis de la commission européenne pour
faire capoter l'interdiction alors
l'autriche va-t-elle réellement sortir
du glyphosate en 2020 réponse après les
législatives anticipées du 29 septembre
et pour prolonger le débat jacques trois
invités jérémy de ces halles bonjour
vous êtes un nouveau député européen la
république en marche
rattaché donc ici au groupe we knew il y
à peu vous étiez encore à la tête des
jeunes agriculteurs et vous êtes éleveur
de vaches charolaises en saône et loire
d'un revenu également sur ce plateau
benoît biteau vous aussi vous avez été
élu député européen en mai dernier sur
la liste europe écologie les verts vous
siégez donc au groupe les verts et vous
partagez votre temps entre le parlement
et votre ferme biologique en charente
maritime c'est ça bienvenue enfin gilles
lebreton vous avez entamé votre deuxième
mandat ici au parlement européen en tant
que député du rassemblement national
vous si j'ai donc au sein du groupe
identité démocratie et vous fait
également partie de la commission
agriculteurs agriculture bonjour à tous
les trois jours c'est que l'union
européenne n'a pas réussi à faire en
novembre 2010 est à savoir interdire le
glyphosate l'autriche l'a fait comment
vous l'expliquez jérémy de serre avant
toute chose déjà si on prend ce qui nous
a été présenté dans le reportage
li a aucun élément contradictoire à
l'interdiction du nifff aux at il ya
personne qui dit ben voilà on peut aussi
se passer progressivement de cette
molécule
donc là on parle vraiment d'interdiction
2020 sans forcément se poser toutes les
questions l'impact que cela peut avoir
est-ce qu'on ce qu'il faut à mon avis ne
pas négliger c'est l'évolution que
connaît le monde agricole européen et
français
parce qu'on est aussi dans une émission
la française cac a connu ces dernières
années tous les agriculteurs sont
aujourd'hui prêts à relever ce défi là
il y en a qui le font plus vite que
d'autres
benoît en est un exemple voilà et il y
en a d'autres qui sont prêts à le faire
il faut juste ne pas négliger tout ce
qui a déjà été fait et je pense que la
france et l'europe est plutôt à
l'entente la matière et que ça ça doit
être prise en compte
on voit aussi dans le reportage de
fabien rey caire que l'interdiction en
autriche et bien elle est menacée
puisque ça dépend et ça a été un
contexte politique un petit peu partout
qu'il y ait troublé on sait qu'il ya des
élections législatives qui arrivent et
la donne pourrait changer à nouveau
monsieur lebreton
ah oui tout à fait la donne peut changer
mais ça peut changer en autriche mais
chez nous c'est en train de changer
aussi je crois qu'il ne faut pas
attaquer nos agriculteurs qui sont très
très inquiets de la mauvaise image
qu'ils ont à l'heure actuelle dans
l'opinion publique parce que ils ont
fait beaucoup d'efforts pour utiliser de
moins en moins de glyphosate
il tient à le rappeler et et nous au
rassemblement national dans mon groupe
identité démocratie on a une position
très nuancée sur la question c'est à
dire que nous sommes favorables à
l'interdiction à terme du glyphosate
c'est un produit cancérogène s'étaient
reconnus par l'organisation mondiale
nous nous sommes jeunes nous sommes
d'accord avec le délai de cinq ans qui
avait été donné par l'union européenne
pour en finir avec ce produit ça va
permettre aux agriculteurs de continuer
leurs efforts et de trouver des produits
ou des méthodes de substitution habito
c'est que on doit absolument aujourd'hui
placé l'agriculture dans un véritable
débat de société
l'erreur que nous pouvons faire et on le
fait trop souvent ici au parlement
européen
ces deux de placer les sujets dans des
logiques corporatistes et ne demander
l'avis aux agriculteurs pour parler du
glyphosate par exemple et aidant le
chargé avec les consommateurs
pourquoi est ce que l'europe est
impliqué sur le sujet agricole c'est
parce que beaucoup d'argent public et
mobiliser pour accompagner l'agriculture
et donc aux motifs de la mobilisation de
cet argent public on doit nécessairement
replacer le débat agricole le sujet
agricole dans un débat de société parce
qu'on mobilise beaucoup d'argent public
et que l'agriculture le fondamental
c'est produire de la nourriture et
produire de la nourriture qui ne
contient pas des substances qui peuvent
mettre en danger la santé des
consommateurs mais aussi le climat mais
aussi les biodiversité mais aussi la
ressource en eau est donc dans cette
approche globale on doit se poser la
question du principe de précaution quand
on utilise du glyphosate le principe de
précaution à ce moment là est ce que ce
n'est pas une interdiction dès demain
monsieur lebreton écouter non parce que
si on interdisait dès demain le
glyphosate ça mettra en péril beaucoup
d'exploitations agricoles
il est nécessaire de donner le temps aux
agriculteurs de s'adapter à la nouvelle
donne et puis aussi de donner le temps à
la recherche scientifique de trouver
d'autres produits ça nécessite forcément
un accompagnement le passage au bio
jérémy dos et relais mais ça nécessite
aussi plus de moyens mais le passage au
bio ou la réduction ou finalement
l'évolution des pratiques sur une
exploitation
celui qui passait au bio il le réfléchit
ça se fait pas du jour au lendemain et
ça nécessite effectivement
l'accompagnement mais au niveau moyen
plus ça a été dit je pense qu autour de
la table on essaye d'être le plus
rationnelle possible va tout le monde
s'exprime là dessus il ya quand même
derrière aussi des agriculteurs il ya
quand même des réalités qui font que
c'est pas non plus bon pour tout le
monde que demain matin tous les
agriculteurs français ou aux repères
changent leurs pratiques parce que ils
n'y arriveront pas tous et on continuera
de manger quand même des produits qui
viennent d'ailleurs et qui ne respectent
pas les conditions vous parler du
malaise agricole en france des arrêtés
municipaux anti pesticides et le projet
et 2 et mtc zone de long traitement
eh bien il semble que ce soit la goutte
d'eau de trop pour les agriculteurs ils
ont manifesté leur désarroi il ya deux
jours en aliments ce qu'ils ont appelé
les feux de la colère je vous propose
d'écouter l'un d'entre eux qu'un lobby
je pense
écolo l'écolo cobo qui veut essayer de
faire à 150 mètres 10 m ou 5 mètres d
éditer par rapport à des riverains et je
veux dire ici dans la métropole lilloise
il serait très très mal perçu parce que
moi par exemple sur mon exploitation
moi je perdrais pour cinq mètres je
perdrais à peu près cinq lecteurs on
voit un agriculteur qui en a marre
d'être stigmatisés à vous disait benoît
biteau il faut que tout le monde se
penche cette question à l'école alors
comment on fait l'europe
déjà le fait que des maires doivent
saisir un arrêté municipal pour essayer
de faire avancer ce débat sur les
pesticides illustre au moins une chose
c'est que ce gouvernement n'a pas pris à
bras le corps le sujet des pesticides et
ne l'a pas placé dans ce débat de
socialistes récit qu'on n'attend plus
que l'aval de l'état où l'union
européenne si l'état avait fait son
travail
les maires des communes ne serait pas
obligé sous la pression de leurs
administrés de prendre ce genre d'arrêté
préfectoral municipal pardon donc ça
c'est une première illustration
après moi je s'en vouloir mais je trouve
le propos de ceux de cet agriculteur un
peu méprisant à l'égard de ceux qui
n'utilise pas de pesticides et aidants
et dans le dans la même veine les propos
du ministre de la culture qui dit que si
on ne traite plus on a affaire à des
friches
on a affaire à la disparition de
l'activité agricole ça veut dire que des
paysans qui comme moi n'utilise plus de
pesticides depuis 13 ans je touche du
bois je n'ai pas fait un seul traitement
depuis 13 ans l'homme à faire et
pourtant je suis en agriculture de
conservation des sols comme le roumain
qu'on l'autriche on a vu tout à l'heure
dans le sujet donc c'est bien la preuve
qu'on peut faire de l'agriculture de
conservation des sols sans forcément
avoir recours au glyphosate
donc je trouve ça méprisant à l'égard de
ceux qui font la démonstration justement
qu'on peut parfaitement produire en
agriculture sans avoir recours aux
pesticides est ce qu'on peut se passer
de pesticides pour toutes les cultures
ont fait pousser des fraises en espagne
que l'on soit viticulteurs en grèce où
que l'on fasse pousser des céréales aux
pays bas est ce que en fait il faut la
même réponse pour tous vient mais de
serre je pense encore une fois qu'il
faut pas non plus exagérer le débat si
vous voulez sur cette question là moi il
ya quelque chose qui m'a fortement agacé
le vendredi soir où est sorti l'arrêté
municipal du maire d'obernai la question
française et je reviens quand même la
question france est ce que c'est ça ça
prend tout son sens aussi c'est yann
arthus bertrand qui est venu sur les
plateaux télé expliqué à quelle distance
fallait traiter
j'en remets pas en cause ses talents de
photographe il prend des très jolies
photos
par contre un peu plus de doutes sur ses
qualités scientifiques et quand on a une
agence qui s'appelle landes c'est ce
dont on ne peut quand même pas non plus
voilà regretter qu'elle existe parce que
le problème est la non sanitaire
française
voilà voilà qui dit qui donne quelques
directives à suivre et bien on peut
aussi de temps en temps faire confiance
à la science
et je rejoins juste deux mots je rejoins
ce que dit benoît oui on peut changer
mais ça se fera pas du jour
demain et les maires en prenant des
arrêtés malgré tout fige des zones du
jour au lendemain je suis d'accord avec
ça je pense que les arrêtés municipaux
ne sont pas une bonne réponse au
problème
je voudrais revenir un petit peu à
l'europe au début de l'année 2019 une
commission du parlement européen rendait
ses conclusions
avec recommandations je cite une refonte
du système d'évaluation des pesticides
afin d'obtenir plus de transparence
d'indépendance agence européenne et une
stricte application du principe de
précaution on y revient ça veut dire
quoi monsieur lebreton qu'il ya un
problème dans l'évaluation de la
dangerosité des pesticides
ça veut dire qu'à mon sens il ne faut
pas remettre en cause la dangerosité du
glyphosate
moi je pense qu'elle est malheureusement
acquise mais qu'il faut encourager la
recherche pour développer d'autres
d'autres types d'herbicides qui serait
moins nocifs pour la santé humaine
il faut encourager la recherche est ce
que tente de faire l'autriche de ce
point de vue est intéressant puisque
l'autriche est en avance sur le
développement d'autres méthodes car moi
je pense que le temps qu'il faut dire la
vérité la france a pris un peu de retard
en ce domaine mais on est en train je
pense d'eux le de le rattraper
grâce aussi au vote du parlement
européen en 2017 qui a qui a contribué à
demander une évolution et donc il ne
faut pas s'affoler c'est pour ça que les
maires donnent pas la bonne solution
parce arrêté d'interdiction mais il faut
que nous réfléchissions ensemble et
rapidement voulu répondre à celui sur
l'évaluation effectivement il faut
refondre complètement la méthode
d'évaluation des pesticides par les
agences sanitaires qu'elle soit
européenne ou nationale parce que elles
sont éculés obsolète depuis depuis
plusieurs décennies le glyphosate n'est
qu' un cas d'école pour la problématique
globale des pesticides
mais quand une agence sanitaire autorise
des molécules sur la base du dossier
déposé par le la firme chimique qui veut
le faire homologuer quand elle n'intègre
pas les faits quant à elle quand elle
n'intègre pas la possibilité de nuisance
des métabolites issus de
des molécules elle-même quand elle
n'évalue pas la nocivité des pesticides
sur le milieu marin alors que toutes les
autres finissent en mer
on voit bien qu'on a une difficulté
grave sur l'évaluation et sur les
alternatives
est-ce que les alternatives sont des
nouvelles molécules à imaginer où est-ce
qu'on doit pas significativement engagé
les crédits européens sur des
alternatives basées sur l'agronomie et
d'agro écologie qui nous éloigne
définitivement des molécules de synthèse
qui sont dangereuses et on revient sur
le principe de précaution vous parlez de
produire autrement jérémy decerle il
faut également nourrir toute l'europe
le maintien de l'agriculture réside dans
la capacité que les consommateurs auront
attiré aussi les modèles vers le haut et
c'est aux consommateurs également de
d'exiger des changements d'accompagner
ces changements d ensemencement ce qui a
faim quand je dis qu'on est irrationnel
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
effectivement qu'il ya un problème avec
les pesticides effectivement qu'il faut
à kusel pour de nouvelles molécules ont
mis la rage udpci je suis pour de
nouvelles alternatives qui permettent
il ya des dangers il ya des risques d
unité interne hâtives et bien d une des
nouvelles pratiques qui permettent
justement de se passer provisoirement
des pesticides et que l'on puisse du
coup nourrit d'imagés de nouvelles
molécules pourquoi provisoirement
nouveau nom mais provisoirement plus tôt
enfin de manière pas direct c'est qu'un
progression dans les rues des manières
il a laissé ce que je veux dire dans
l'irrationalité qui est un peu ambiante
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe il
n'y a pas des morts en rempart 4
tous les matins ni chez les agriculteurs
ni chez les consommateurs à cause des
produits phytosanitaires
par contre tous les deux jours et un
agriculteur qui suicide
voir tous les jours voir tous les jours
dans certaines zones en plus ou dans
certaines productions
il ne suffit sud suscite pas tous à
cause d'eux depuis fait d'être montré du
doigt ou d'être un peu catalogué comme
des pollueurs mais ça joue beaucoup et
donc c'est pour ça que le consommateur
aussi nous autres politiques et j'allais
dire l'ensemble aussi d organisation des
filières d organiser
la scion agricole nous devons trouver
des solutions pour accompagner aussi les
agriculteurs sur ce sujet messieurs ce
seront les mots de la fin mai avant de
se quitter à vous êtes à la jérémy de
serre les benoît biteau tous les deux
nouveaux députés européens monsieur
breton c'est votre deuxième mandat je
suis en vie dans un hameau votre
impression sur ses premiers pas au
parlement
benoît biteau c'est d'abord une très
très belle aventure je ne suis
absolument pas déçu
c'est conforme à ce que j'espérais c'est
même peut-être mieux que ce que
j'espérais et et surtout contrairement à
ce que certains ont l'habitude de dire
les gens qui dénigrent le champ
politique moi je pense qu'il ya des
vraies marges de manoeuvre pour les
députés qui font le travail et qui est
qui et qui s'attelle au dossier pour
débattre comme ici gérer mais decerle
vos premiers pas ici au parlement ça se
passe bien je vais pas m'ennuyer
c'est la fin de cette émission vous
pouvez la voir on replay sur les sites
internet des chaînes parlementaires mais
aussi sur l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures européennes merci merci merci
[Musique]